wo bist du nein nein nein nein das kann
doch nicht wahr sein 65
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
wie dropper zusammen mit dem kram kraft
aber dem der letzte part war unter dem
auch der nächste part sein wird bei mir
heute ohne face cam weil die voll ist
wegen megaprojekt aufnahmen mit den und
simon deswegen ja ohne festen und knapp
die gc so du mir gibst du kannst du gar
nicht glauben ich super good day
naja sein falls wir haben kein
gleichstand sondern ich habe vier erst
sechs und bei der letzten folge guckt
euch am besten bei kran kräften letzte
folge und dann ganz am ende oder
verlängere oder oder das intro
geschnitten ja ja genau das war so guckt
euch einfach an ich will ganz verraten
guckt euch einfach an das ist heftig
aber ich hab mich so aufgeregt denn ich
wollte ich so rum schreibe meine eltern
hier sind und alles möglich aber oh
scheiße war das einfach nur egal wer
spielt das level 11 level 11 amor
übrigens ab dienst geschrieben das wir
schilder lesen sollen machen wir jetzt
aber sind ja fast keine schilder nur bei
dem lava levels halt heftig wir müssen
uns während des falls die ganzen sachen
anziehen
du musst während des falls auf jeden
fall alles anziehen und du musst einfach
in der mitte bleiben glaube ich so alt
ist heftig ich habe nur diamant sachen
anbinden der mitte ich habe alle sachen
an sich auch alter
einfach in der mitte bleiben naja du
einfach in der mitte bleiben aber ich
war hatte alle sachen an diamant helm so
das engl
man kann das nicht überleben doch du
musst die sachen anziehen die verzaubert
sind mit schutz neulich hab ich hab's
geschafft
hey als ob ich war gerade eben auch
schon unten habe ich bin gestorben
vielleicht hat vielleicht zieht nehmen
musst du musst es gibt verschiedene
sachen
hier muss echten flug anziehen ja und es
gibt das auch geschafft
ich würde jetzt aber erst warten bevor
den schwarzen knopfdruck bist allerdings
fertig ist aber egal drück ich mache
wenn du wenn du den drückst dann wird
dir einen spot für hier gesetzt
ja aber nicht weil wir nur hoch springst
du bist dann oben
ich sehe einfach keine kiste ich sehe
die kiste schon eine resistenz ist weg
scheiße die kiste auf den weißen okay
ich mein zeug
ich stelle mich daneben eine sekunde 0
sekunden und diamant ja ich hab ja man
nie
ich finde sowas kannst du bist ganz
leise max mit derzeit wahrscheinlicher
aber ich rede mir einfach und zwar vor
hin was halt einfach so hat
wahrscheinlich die szene jetzt eh schon
links geguckt und zwar weil ich vor der
kiste hast du gesagt so ich muss auch
zwei sekunden musste noch einen block
hoch bevor ich daran kamen
und wenn ich dann gesprungen würde ich
hatte halt diese sprung verstärkung
deshalb so gewesen wäre gestorben weil
ich so hoch wie jetzt habe ich den
fluten verloren dann jedoch nicht ich
habe noch im internet gut
ich dachte schon und kriegte ich jetzt
mal mit der micro hat das hier heftig
ich verstehe immer noch so banal wie
jetzt gerade geht es wieder
jetzt bin ich bin ganz erfordern bleibe
ich einfach so ruhig hätten ich hätte
mir einfach klauen können aber das wäre
es gewesen ich habe jetzt sowieso mehr
diamanten und soweit ich dann auch nicht
sein
also ich habe nur ein paar unterstützen
kann eingebildete sauer so bin ich nicht
ich bin lucia sie rechne hunger games
runde wohnt üblich verteidigt hast du
dir einfach getötet sagt uns nicht du
bist nicht asi das war kein hunger games
ist beim 18 12 12 drag cars the triumph
en la die pumpkins läuft auf jeden
verbinden das mega krasses rückzug
reaper auf cards unterwegs kann man ihn
irgendwo ein sprung verstärken will
ich kann ihnen gar nicht springen ich
verstehe ich warum ich kann nichts
bringen
ich kann echt nicht springen ich auch
nicht
also fällt es gab also auf dauer doch du
musst du musst noch früher ab springt
alles geschafft
oh ja ok aber ich habe irgendwie müssen
anfangen über aber wie kriegen wir die
den weg wir müssen eigentlich ein
schwert haben oder irgend sowas max geht
es denn gerade von der qualität bei mir
also dein zwei quali hat sich bei mir
zumindest klar dass es passiert einfach
alles ist ihm kann die map zerstört
werden dann haben jetzt ein problem
nicht
das war knapp alter bleiben
jetzt muss ich schauen wo bist du denn
also ich hab ich weiß nicht wo ich
anfangen muss ich habe mir einfach aus
meinte ich weiß nicht wo ich anfangen
erst einmal eine entgegengekommen
japan kämpfe ich habe die kiste gesehen
aber du bist gestorben ich habe die
kiste gesehen aber ich glaube dann kommt
da nicht zu sterben
ich will mir nicht sicher dass etwas auf
dem tisch da unten
lass dir einfach zeit halt dein maul
scheiße alter sorgte der falsche weg den
ich gegangen bin okay kommt schon
construction corporation überlebt ist
gestoppt ja hier nicht wusstest du hast
also springt runter du denkst nicht nach
max ich denke aber ich will nicht
nachdenken das stand probleme hin
ich weiß nicht schaffe diesen sprung in
die seite hier soll natürlich nicht
scheiße du kannst einfach nicht nach
man springt ja wenigstens du penner ich
bin auch genügend fans
ich versteh ich weiß das nicht weil man
von keeper hier hingegen schildere ich
geil seid ihr zahngold wo ich weiß wo es
lang geht ja weiß ich auch nein jetzt
doch was mich gesehen
nee hab ich s bahn kann man seinen sport
setzen hat wo habe ich denn julia kommt
mir halt alle einfach entgegen
klickt euch man kann ja nicht mal gucken
oder das 1 1 gegen kommt also ja ich
glaub ich habe nen dicken vorsprung auf
dich warum hast du jemanden nehmen die
diamanten nicht aber ich habe den weg
gefunden
ich bin schon 1000 meter weiter ist cool
ich habe sie nie ich habe die nächsten
köbes gefunden soll jetzt ein ende wenn
er den kürbis york stand der dow unten
steht
und zwar muss man daran dieses
reinspringen der kiste für kiste so
diamanten geholt jetzt spiele ich auf
den pumpkin doch ich glaube es ist
langsam max walsleben weil ihr das das
leben
wo muss ich denn jetzt springt da unten
sind auch mal so spinnen weben du bist
du denn luca bei den spinnen weben so
hier
nein ich bin auf den stolzen da ist egal
drückt den knopf an ich muss in der auf
krücken in den baum gehen da unten
sonntag kommt hier unten stehst du musst
runterspringen ich weiß dass ich runter
springen muss hier vorne wo ich stehe
wohin fährst du denn dann erst die fahne
ist doch normal zur kiste der blauen
knopf der war hier auch eine davon ist
überhaupt wichtig ist der ausflügler
hast du willst du hin gerne selber
nichts drin der mich jetzt verstarb ihr
mann hast jetzt 75 na gut level 13
schild dna step by step filings press at
the bottom
jeder fall steht hat musst du angst hast
du wirklich
danke für den tipp das ist geil
ich weiß gar nicht dass so was gibt dass
diese sachen spawn was bordellen des
bond oder gibt es noch was hat der denn
was ist das und fliegende boote läuft
bei ihnen junge alles das ist echt krass
diese ganzen welt besuchen abgestürzt ja
aber das ist mal was machen fehler fall
also dass man nicht so viele chancen
kriegen das dass ihr mich ab
regeneration
ich habe den knopf gedrückt dass ich
wieder zurück zum start level kommen
höhere level 13
auf den kisten ich bin auf der suche
nach dem rest der rüstung ich bin mit
anderen weg gelaufen warum recht sicher
dass noch mehr richtung gibt klare nicht
geschenkt stärkung das wenn du runter
fällt das du das überlebt aber das gibt
es ja nun auch schon
es gibt nur federball soweit ich weiß er
aber allgemein wenn rüstung hast
überlebten den absturz und da es in eine
klink wer glaube ich gewesen ja luca ich
bin auf dem weg der kürbisse scheiße
scheiße ich auch aber ich habe nichts
mehr gefunden auch man verkaufe ich bin
dann vorbei geflogen was denn mit
lohnenswert nein das so eine gloucester
und kuppel kuppel kuppe hier langfristig
hier laden
man muss den kürbis im lande stellt ja
doch noch soldatin kürbisse hier ist
kürbisse wo ist der nächste da unten das
überlebe ich locker easy locker wie sie
ein herz um man hier ist nächster kirch
warf einen richtig guten weg da kann es
auf jeden fall nicht runter will muss
tief auf jeden fall aber wie komme ich
von ihr tief ich bin doch hier geht es
nicht mehr tiefer das einfach das wäre
die auf einer ebene ist fasst ihre
schöne oder wenn es so wäre hier ein
junge
ich war schon mal bei dem oder soll ich
einfach weiterhin ihren rechten ich mach
den weg einfach noch mal genauso und
springen einfach auf dem blog der ein
wenig höher waren die news den kürbissen
folgen mache ich ja ich habe auch willst
du denn bei dabei kugelsicher ecke
schwersten kürbisse
das heißt sie muss jetzt runter jetzt
noch einen schritt vor gemessen [ __ ]
warum fällt mir so weit aber erst 30
nicht tue ich bin auf jeden fall schon
recht weit unten luca unter hier
ich folge den kürbissen lukas schon fast
ganz unten
quaid max und ich will dass du dich
behalten so hier jetzt hier auf den
kürbis neulich verschärfen sie spielen
auf den kürbis und sterbe naja warten
vielleicht suche ich mir mal von anderen
weg hier lang lang irland wo ich bin
meinem schwarzen knopf ihr wald so dass
der kürbis springe ich da auf den kürbis
und wohin jetzt leute praktisch
abgestürzt aber vorm schwarzen haben der
forschung gerückt vielleicht meinen
gespeichert so ich springe jetzt auf
diesen kürbis debatte hier reden ob es
eine andere königs oder sehr höher da
ist nicht mehr helfen ich noch irgendein
anderer ist so heftig hier ich habe
keine ahnung wo die kiste ist ich bin
beim schwarzen knopf er was laberst du
springst denen den links hinterher
den kürbis ist einfach herunter gefallen
nein ich bin mit gewissen gefolgt muss
wirklich den kürbissen folgen nämlich
pin den gewissen gefolgt ich sterbe wäre
einfach nichts oder springt auf den
falschen kögel
ich habe die kiste gefunden du musst von
chur bis zur kirbe springen oder nein
also der linie von den kürbissen musste
folgen also wurde der letzte kürbis ist
ist der schwarze knapp bürger wir machen
es jetzt spannend wenn ich vor der kiste
stehe dann mache ich ein timer an eine
minute und dann muss sie probieren da
hin zu können in einer minute um die
schwöre ich mache es nicht vorher auf ok
ja ich bin ja auf dem weg nach unten
aber ich versteh ich folglich den kürbis
nicht meinen eigenen weg allahs die
kürbisse
ok also ich bin ziemlich sicher bei der
kiste ja ich stehe jetzt die tolle leute
wurde jetzt in springen das ziel ich
keinen schaden kriege hier ist der
kürbis surfen gestorben
das heißt wenn ich darunter falle dürfte
ich eigentlich keinen schaden bekommen
braucht die schule gar nicht anhält und
ich lache
jetzt geht es also viel besser junge
alter ich habe die schuhe anziehen
müssen
doch ich auch dass ich das geschrieben
haben so hier ist ein kürbis
ja auf jeden fall runter und hier so
luca ich jetzt genau vor der kiste
ich mache jetzt ein countdown an eine
minute wenn du früher da bist dann
kriegst du hast doch so bitter alter
guck mal wird ein bisschen nach rechts
wachstum also neben wir hier nach rechts
hier hier hier hier nein nach rechts
nicht nach hinten
ja es so scheiße aber hier sind die
kästen 54 diese kunden und lieferanten
ging es ist doch so einfach wie komme
ich denn jetzt darüber 30 sekunden 35
lkw nicht du kannst dir den von mir aus
nämlich wichtig so ein scheiß countdown
an den diamanten kriegen hätte ist doch
lustig muss einfach die dings runter
einfach runter ja wer das nicht auf zeit
wir dann würde ich mich auch
konzentrieren würden hier noch meinem
youtube halt einmal ich will keine
minuten
er guckt da unten genau da unten ist es
demnächst schon dieser schwarze knopf
das noch so eine scheiße wäre so hier
runter ich habe richtig bock am ende wir
wollen müssen die metro in die luft
sprengen am ende weil sie nicht wenn man
nicht versteht er das so langweilig wie
getränk
ich bin kein spieler gehen 30 sie
konnten hast du machen von meinen ganz
countdown
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] nein du bist du 10 965
mit dem was ich schenk dir den diamanten
aber jetzt max nicu wieder schlecht aber
jetzt ist auch der part vorbei deswegen
marktversagen weil der micro ii das
alles wieder wegnimmt
wenn es euch gefallen hat durch die
gerne hoch geben oder halt in die
kommentare schreiben ob wir wieder etwas
meckern habt und schreibt man alle max
der soziale weil damit hat er sein
soziales klischeehaftes verhalten wieder
aufpäppeln können durch einen medien
tritt hier als probe für seinen kanal
nächste folge ist bei krankhafter und
dann sehen wir uns morgen bei ihm wieder
ciao